CNN: It spans the globe like a super highway,
it is called “Internet.”
David Bowie: I think we’re actually on the
cusp of something exhilarating and terrifying.
Jeremy Paxman: It’s just a tool though isn’t
it?
David Bowie: No, it’s not, no.
It’s an alien life form.
ABC Science: It’s going to get woven into
the daily fabric of our lives.
It will just be like using a telephone, it’ll
be like using your car on the roads, we take
it for granted.
If I wanted to talk to someone on the far
side of the world it would be just as natural
as me talking to you now.
SIERRA: The Internet.
What was once a marvel is now something our
modern world depends on for, well, everything.
It allows us access.
Access to crucial information, not-so-crucial
information, and access to each other.
But not everyone’s access is created equally.
In fact, it may no longer be accurate to think
of THE internet as a single entity.
That’s because around the world, different
governments have taken very different approaches
to regulating the internet, shaping what their
citizens access online and how their private
data is tracked.
And this has led to a splintering.
The world now has three primary “internets”:
One led by the United States, one led by China,
and one led by the European Union.
And if things keep going as they are, we could
be headed toward an even more divided digital
world.
My name is Gabrielle Sierra and this is Why
It Matters.
Today the world’s three internets and what
they mean for our future.
SEGAL: For most users, they still see one
internet, right?
You're going to go on the internet, you're
going to search for whatever it's going to
be, K-pop band, and you're going to see all
the highlights and you're going to get all
that stuff.
SIERRA: This is Adam Segal.
He directs the Digital and Cyberspace Policy
Program here at the Council.
He recently led an independent task force
which further details U.S. national security
innovations for defending an open and secure
internet.
SEGAL: But what we're beginning to see is
that governments are regulating and thinking
about how the internet should be regulated
very differently.
And there are three major models.
There's the way that the United States has
done it, there is the way that China has done
it from the beginning, which is much more
restrictive.
And then there's a European model that kind
of blends the American focus on human rights
and openness with more of a tendency towards
government regulation.
WHEELER: The nature of what we're talking
about when we say three internets is a regulatory
environment, a climate, and some degree of
authoritative control over how that information
flows.
SIERRA: This is Tarah Wheeler.
She is Senior Fellow for Global Cyber Policy
here at the Council, and CEO of Red Queen
Dynamics, a cybersecurity company.
WHEELER: A lot of the question around what
constitutes an internet is who is allowed
to listen to what you're doing and do something
about it, and how much of your time do you
have to put into enabling that for that third
party?
That's really what it kind of boils down to
is what is this regime, what does this internet
think it has the right and responsibility
to do with you as an internet user?
Whether that's by turning off the tap, literally
severing a transatlantic cable, or simply
because a government can control the internet
service providers inside their territory and
mandate that they shut those off.
We see that there are three different real
manifestations of what constitutes an internet
in the world.
SIERRA: So that means that if there are three
people, one in New York, one in Beijing, one
in Berlin, and they all look up the same thing,
let's say K-Pop, their experiences are going
to be different based on where they are geographically?
SEGAL: Yes.
Not with K-pop, K-pop probably they get all
the same answers.
But, the classic example with China is, you
look up Tank Man.
Tank Man is the picture of the individual
standing in front of a line of tanks after
the People's Liberation Army cracked down
on the democracy movement in Tiananmen in
1989.
If you Google that in the United States and
Europe, you get that image, you get to see
that picture.
You Google that in China, you don't get anything,
because the Chinese don't want young Chinese
to know about Tiananmen happening, and so
that image doesn't exist in China.
It's controlled.
If you Google Tiananmen in China, you just
get a picture of beautiful Tiananmen and probably
some PLA soldier raising the flag in the morning.
Similarly, if you were to Google Mein Kampf
the book in the United States, you would get
the Wikipedia entry and you'd probably get
a link to buy it on Amazon.
But in a lot of European states, and in Germany
in particular, you would get the Wikipedia
link, but you would not get the link to buy
Mein Kampf, right?
Because you can't buy Nazi paraphernalia in
Germany because they have restrictions on
that, because of historical reasons.
SIERRA: And not only will your search results
vary, the information collected on you as
you search will also change.
This is a lot to digest, so let’s dig deeper
into each of these internets, starting with
the United States model.
PBS NewsHour: Google, Facebook, Amazon, Apple,
are among the most powerful monopolies in
the history of humanity.
Wall Street Journal: They develop these products
and services that have made such a deep impact
into the lives of so many people on an everyday
basis.
CNBC: Let’s, meanwhile, note that Apple
just hit the three trillion dollar mark in
total market cap.
Al Jazeera: After months of uncertainty and
a long legal battle, the world’s wealthiest
man has now taken charge of one of the most
influential social media platforms.
Senator Orrin Hatch: How do you sustain a
business model in which users don’t pay
for your service?
Mark Zuckerburg: Senator, we run ads.
SEGAL: The United States internet is driven
by two big principles.
The First Amendment, so free speech, and then
a very, very light regulatory hand from the
government.
So the internet sector was not taxed at the
beginning, it was not regulated for the most
part.
And so it grew because of that, and it allowed
for this free exchange of ideas.
But the U.S. is unique in having a First Amendment.
Other democracies don't have a First Amendment.
Other democracies have what they consider
legitimate reasons to control speech because
of concerns about communal violence or because
of their history.
So from an innovative perspective, I think
there's little doubt that the U.S. is still
driving it.
Although we are beginning to see the emergence
of Chinese tech platforms, TikTok being the
big one that no one really expected to see.
But innovative perspective is still there.
There has been over the last five years a
real sense of the information the tech firms
have about us, and how they use it in ways
that we don't necessarily control, plus the
kind of negative social impacts, right?
So how that plays on teenagers and others
who are constantly checking in and all these
other things.
From a political perspective, what we see
is both the right and the left, the Democrats
and the Republicans are very unhappy for different
reasons.
The Democrats and the Left have become unhappy
both because of the rise of misogyny and transphobia
and racism and the fact that a lot of these
platforms have become places for abuse.
Now from the Right's perspective, they are
worried about tech’s control over free speech.
And so a lot of the things that, when Twitter
or Facebook takes something down, the Right
tends to see it as stifling speech, free speech.
So, the Right attacked Big Speech from that
perspective.
And then the Right and the Left both are unhappy
with Big Tech because of anti monopoly, big
trust.
Do they dominate the markets too much?
BRADFORD: So there's much good that has been
accomplished.
But I think we are increasingly aware of the
downsides of the internet as well.
SIERRA: This is Anu Bradford.
She is the Henry L. Moses Professor of Law
and International Organization at Columbia
Law School.
BRADFORD: The idea that it's not only a medium
to force the beneficial societal debates that
contribute towards more vibrant and participatory
democracy, the internet is also rampant with
disinformation that destabilizes our democracies
with hate speech that compromises our dignity.
Those are just some examples of how we've
sort of gotten both things, we've gotten the
good, but we've also gotten a lot of harmful
effects, with all those connections.
And also, I think nobody was able to predict
just how powerful these leading internet platforms
would become.
So the kind of market power that these companies
have the kind of economic and political and
cultural and societal influence they exert,
that is something that has really shaped societies
in a way that can be very different, what
sort of democratic societies would look like,
if that power was rooted in real sort of democratic
governance.
Another concern is the privacy of individuals.
SIERRA: According to Pew, 68% of internet
users believe current laws are not good enough
in protecting people’s privacy online.
Which kind of makes sense since the most important
law when it comes to the U.S. internet, called
Section 230, actually protects companies not
users.
It frees companies like Facebook or Twitter
from liability for the content that its users
post on their platforms.
Some experts have referred to Section 230
as “the 26 words that created the Internet,”
because it freed startups to move quickly
without fear of lawsuits.
There are limited protections in the United
States for certain types of highly sensitive
information, like health data or social security
numbers.
But there is no agency, or set of laws, that
were created exclusively to protect the digital
privacy of Americans.
However, if you live in states like California
or Connecticut, you may benefit from state-level
data protections.
But overall, it’s sort of a mess.
BRADFORD: So, our lives have become exposed
to these companies that are in a position
to extract our data and commercialize that
data in ways that really deprives individuals
of their privacy.
And one could say to sort of compromise the
autonomy and ability to make decisions, when
that data can be used, then, to manipulate
the choices that we make online.
SIERRA: Social psychologist Shoshana Zuboff
coined a term for this: ‘surveillance capitalism.’
Basically, U.S. corporations claim private
human experiences as free raw data.
So, the same phone that you use to navigate
to your favorite restaurant tracks your every
move, often when you’re not even using your
GPS.
Every key word you search, every link you
click, and every purchase you make goes into
algorithms that shape your consumer profile.
This can feel icky, even spooky.
And it's not the only problem that Americans
face online.
There’s also a steady stream of toxic, polarizing,
and misleading content.
WHEELER: The internet does feel more toxic
right now.
We do talk about people, women, people who
are non-binary, people of color getting bullied,
experiencing this toxicity out there.
But on a lot of levels, that comes as a result
of the democratization of the internet.
We let the assholes onto the internet now
too, and not just the nerds.
SIERRA: Ah, our first ever censorship bleep.
And on the perfect episode.
You gotta love that.
WHEELER: So a lot of the problem we're having
right now is just that it's people using communication
technologies.
So it's going to be an interesting challenge
to see how we handle this toxicity, this problem
of letting just anybody in here without limiting
speech, without limiting the communication
protocols themselves.
SIERRA: Okay, fair.
But do you think it's an easier lift to figure
out how to regulate the place where this is
all happening versus making all humans good
humans?
WHEELER: I think the challenge that we’re
having here is human beings, and the way they
interact with technology often doesn’t really
take into account the fact that they’re
dealing with real people.
So, is it easier to regulate the internet?
Not without some massive unintended consequences
that I think are beyond the ken, understanding,
and desire of the same people who want to
regulate the internet.
You can't ban toxic speech without banning
speech, and you can't ban toxic speech without
defining it.
And there's always going to be people that
think toxic speech is different than your
own definition.
SIERRA: Why is the U.S. so slow or reluctant
to create laws and regulations that curtail
the parts of this that everyone seems so unhappy
with?
SEGAL: Yeah, I think it's because we were
so successful.
Right?
I think the internet grew so fast, and created
such wealth, and became global and is just
this amazing American success story, right?
It was created by DARPA, the Defense Agency
Research Project.
So it is this amazing kind of American invention
that became a global platform.
And we were really afraid to mess it up.
People thought that the regulation would stifle
innovation, and there were real First Amendment
concerns that are still making it really hard
to figure out what we're going to do about
content in the United States.
And then I think there was also some hubris
that everybody would just accept the American
model, and realize that that was in their
best interest.
And I have been in several meetings with U.S.
government officials with a counterpart either
for example, Indian or Chinese for that matter,
where the U.S. tries to lecture to the other
side.
Like ‘no, no, no, a global open internet
is in your best interest.
You're going to lose out on the economic benefits
if you try to control the internet.’
And those countries were like, well one, who
are you to be lecturing us on our own interest?
And two, you're wrong.
We can figure it out about how to control
the internet and still grow.
And the Chinese have, the Chinese have managed
to do that pretty well.
SIERRA: Okay, so that’s the American internet:
overflowing with innovation and profit; but
very light on regulations and privacy.
And that leads us to the other end of the
spectrum: China, home to roughly 1 billion
internet users, and the most regulated internet
system on Earth.
TIME: China’s great firewall just became
even bigger.
Blocking the free flow of information on the
internet even further.
CNN Business: War is already playing out between
the U.S. and China on the technological battlefield.
PBS NewsHour: Huawei and other Chinese telecom
companies are building 5G and smart cities
in more than 65 countries.
Rachel Martin: China is cracking down on mass
protests that broke out over the weekend.
Emily Fang: They’re stopping random people
and checking their phones for apps like telegram
and instagram.
All mentions of them are being deleted online.
And there has been no official acknowledgement
that these demonstrations even happened over
the weekend.
SEGAL: From the very beginning, when China
connected to the internet, they thought of
it as a dual edge sword.
So they knew that the internet was going to
be extremely important for economic development,
but they from the beginning were very worried
about the flow of information from the outside
into China that they couldn't control, that
would threaten the legitimacy and the stability
of the Communist Party.
So what the Chinese did at the very beginning
was block information from the outside, which
we refer to or know as ‘The Great Firewall.’
So, blocking information.
And they blocked U.S. companies that wouldn't
play by those rules.
So we saw Google and Facebook trying to enter
the China market, but then basically having
to pull back because they were unwilling to
censor, or eventually the cost of censoring
became too much for them so they withdrew
from the market.
SIERRA: Across the world, when you sign on
to the internet, you find the same companies
- Google, Facebook, Amazon and the rest of
the American giants.
They may look a bit different based on location,
but they’re there.
Once you cross over into China though, that
changes completely.
Instead of Google, you’ll be searching on
Baidu.
Instead of Amazon, you’ll find yourself
shopping on Alibaba or TaoBao.
For dating, instead of Tinder you may use
Momo or Tantan.
And for social media, you’ll find yourself
using Weibo, QQ, or the incredibly popular
WeChat.
SEGAL: Again, for a Chinese user, if you're
interested in K-pop, the internet is fantastic.
And the Chinese internet has had lots of innovations
that we haven't.
The big one being WeChat, which is a platform
that allows you to do almost everything.
So it's a messenger, and a payment system,
and you can't get a cab without it any longer
in China.
And so it's everything in one place.
And there have been lots OF breakthroughs
on services and things like that in the Chinese
case.
But one way to think about the Chinese internet
is, as we mentioned, The Great Firewall exists
to keep things out.
And then, inside, there are just a lot of
controls to make sure people don't post things
that are against the party.
Real name registration.
Everybody has to register to their accounts,
their social media accounts with their real
name.
There's no anonymity like there is on Twitter.
So, it makes it very easy to get arrested
or called in for questioning.
All the technology companies in China, social
media is responsible for what they post.
So in the United States we have intermediate
liability under something called Section 230,
which says the companies are allowed to take
some things down if they want to, but they're
not legally responsible for what somebody
puts up, if it's not true.
In China, they are responsible, and so they
hire tens of thousands of censors to take
things down.
And then you can be called in if you post
something that the Chinese government doesn't
like, you can be what's called, ‘called
in for tea,’ which means the local ministry
of public security comes by and says, don't
post that again.
SIERRA: I can remember years ago when some
people thought that access to information
would undermine the ability of the communist
party to retain control.
But it doesn't look like that happened.
SEGAL: No, I mean, so there was a great quote
from President Clinton…
Bill Clinton: Now there’s no question China
has been trying to crack down on the internet.
Good luck.
That’s sort of like trying to nail jello
to the wall.
SEGAL: And it turns out that Chinese are pretty
good at nailing jello to the wall.
So there is the question about what access
to information that they get.
But the other thing that we saw is that the
Chinese were not only concerned about the
access to the information, they were really
concerned about organizing.
So any time they saw any type of organization,
then they quickly shut everything down and
really made an example of those people in
real life.
So we see tight controls, we see restrictions
from the outside, and then finally, we see
kind of a flooding.
So, positive messaging about the party and
what a great job the party is doing.
What a great job the government is doing.
This is known as wumao, which is the 50 Cent
Army, which is how much that they were reportedly
paid for each posting.
They would post positive things about Uncle
Xi and what a great job the Chinese Communist
party was doing.
So a very, very tightly controlled internet
cutoff for the most part for internal users
from the rest of the world.
SIERRA: To recap, the Chinese Internet model
shows that it’s possible to control what
a large population is able to see online,
while also regulating what they’re able
to say there.
It’s tightly restricted, and rife with propaganda.
Interestingly though, it does share one common
denominator with the American Internet - in
both places citizen’s data is up for grabs.
In The U.S., it’s exploited by corporations,
whereas in China, it’s exploited by the
government.
And that leads us to the final model: Europe.
WION: The European Union is now proposing
to impose hefty fines to keep the tech giants
in check.
Channel 4 News: Say hello to GDPR.
It's being described as the biggest shake
up of data protection laws in a generation,
giving ordinary people unprecedented control
over the information companies’ hold on
us.
CNBC: We’ve seen anti-trust action from
the European commission.
They fined google a combined 9.5 billion dollars.
TRT World Now: European Union has threatened
to ban Twitter in its territory unless the
company’s owner, Elon Musk, makes sure that
Twitter abides by its laws on content moderation.
SEGAL: What happened very quickly in Europe
was that they decided privacy, data privacy,
was a human right.
Again, a lot of this came out of history.
It came out of World War II and Germany was
a leader on this, that the state collecting
data on you is a step towards fascism and
authoritarian states.
And the technology companies having this kind
of data is also.
So very early on, the Europeans said, well,
we want to regulate how that data's collected,
who has access to it, and to put more restrictions
on it than the United States had on those
provisions.
Now, the Europeans have always said, ‘we
want to encourage innovation and growth,’
but the regulatory environment never really
seemed to grow, right?
It's very hard to think of Big Tech platforms
that came out of Europe.
Spotify is one, Skype is another.
But compared to what came out of Silicon Valley,
it’s much, much less.
BRADFORD: So the EU then really became globally
known as the privacy regulator, when it adopted
the general data privacy regulation, the GDPR
in 2016.
So that is a major piece of regulation focused
on enhancing user privacy, and then restraining
what is known as surveillance capitalism,
the way the platform companies are exploiting
the user's data.
SIERRA: You know those terms of service agreements
that you always sign but never read?
Accepting them often gives private companies
access to an extraordinary amount of data
on your phone.
It’s an open secret - roughly 60 percent
of Americans believe that it’s not possible
to go through a day without having their data
tracked in one way or another.
And on this front, Europe has pushed back
much harder than the U.S.
BRADFORD: So, the privacy has certainly been
one issue.
But the EU has also been very focused on deploying
antitrust laws to reduce the power of the
largest platform.
So that is another element of that regulatory
approach.
And then third, I would say content moderation.
So there's been various voluntary codes, on
mitigating hate speech and disinformation
that the EU has signed with the leading tech
platforms.
And then very recently, so this year, there
was a major piece of legislation that was
adopted, the Digital Services Act, that then
takes this content moderation regulation to
another level.
So the EU is setting binding rules on how
to improve accountability and transparency,
when it comes to content moderation by these
leading platforms.
SIERRA: So if I'm browsing Facebook, which
is an American company, but I'm in the EU,
my privacy would be better protected there,
even though it's from an American company
that doesn't have the same rules?
SEGAL: Yeah, so Facebook operating in Europe
has to abide by those rules.
And so part of those rules are, for example,
there's a right to be forgotten in Europe.
So as a teenager, you might have done something
really dumb, it got posted to Instagram and
it's still up there and you are applying for
jobs now, and you're afraid it's going to
be up there.
In Europe you have the right to ask for that
to be taken out.
SIERRA: Oh, that's nice.
SEGAL: Right?
And so if you're Google or Facebook and there's
a court that rules that if it's a legitimate
reason to take it down, then they'll take
it down.
We don't have that right in the United States.
We're all now partly seeing that right now,
every website we go to there's a pop-up that
asks you about the cookies that you're willing
and the data that you're willing to share.
That's because of European law.
So the operators of those websites either
are operating in Europe at the same time,
and so they have to ensure that the data is
being either stored locally or how it's being
shared in the U.S. is equivalent to what happens
in Europe.
Here’s how it works.
Nations within the EU can fine companies up
to 4% of their annual revenue if they violate
the rules of GDPR.
And this applies to any U.S. company with
EU users.
For example, in 2019, France fined Google
$57 million because they failed to obtain
consent for user’s personalized ads.
GDPR was a win for private users in Europe,
but it caused headaches for companies that
built their business around user data and
targeted ads.
WHEELER: No one paid attention in American
tech companies to GDPR until the day it was
put into force and all of a sudden a bunch
of regulatory filings happened that meant
that American companies could no longer transfer
information inside the European Union unless
they abided by GDPR.
And it was as if all of a sudden the eyes
of every C-level executive other than the
CTO were opened unto the reality of the fact
that there's a world outside of the United
States, and sometimes we have to do what they
want us to do if you want to sell in their
market.
SIERRA: On average, companies are estimated
to have paid more than $1.4 million dollars
each, in order to come into compliance with
the new law.
It was a costly development for the tech sector.
And some experts think that that may have
been the whole point.
WHEELER: Now, why would the European Union
be doing something like this?
First, there's a good strong argument that
a lot of what they're doing is very important
to make sure that they can regulate and handle
speech issues, privacy issues inside the European
Union that are not adequately compensated
for under American law.
We don't have good privacy regulation in the
United States.
It's being done state by state, California,
Colorado had that done state by state, but
we don't have national privacy legislation.
But there's also an underlying frustration,
I think, in the European Union over the fact
that they don't have a native Apple, Google,
Facebook.
There is no giant provider like that in the
European Union.
And so there's a question about whether or
not the EU could regulate their way to having
something like that by trying to level the
playing field or if they could just tax their
way to it.
So again, the question kind of comes to the
point here about whether or not the European
Union is taxing or regulating its way to trying
to be an equal player competitively or because
there's an actual underlying element thereof
desiring to protect citizens.
Could be both, could be neither.​​
SIERRA: So, perhaps the EU’s motivation
is not entirely based on personal privacy.
But other analysts, including Anu, disagree
that regulations like GDPR are motivated by
tech-sector jealousy, or competitive goals.
BRADFORD: The biggest tech companies happen
to be all American.
But they also happen to be the biggest companies
that create the biggest problems in the digital
marketplace.
And if you look at the domain where the EU
has probably gone furthest in it’s regulation,
antitrust, there's been three cases against
Google over 10 billion in fines, yes, the
EU was going after Google.
But who brought the initial complaint?
Tt was Microsoft.
Tt was another American company.
There is no European search engine that the
Europeans are trying to protect when going
after Facebook.
Again, there is no European social media company
that is a rival to Facebook.
Often it is other American companies challenging
the conduct of their competitors in the EU
fighting the civil war in the European territory,
because there's nothing that they can get
from Washington.
SIERRA: Whether you believe that the EU’s
privacy laws were created for the protection
of the people or just to be a thorn in the
side of big American tech, these restrictions
mean a different internet environment.
And whatever you think about it, Europe is
showing the world that it’s possible to
have the Internet and a bit of privacy too.
SIERRA: So what, does the future hold?
Who will come out on top of the three internets?
SEGAL: I don't know if there's going to be
a winner.
I think there's going to be spheres of influence.
I think there's a lot of authoritarian developing
states that are going to find parts of the
Chinese model attractive.
The Chinese have the resources to help them
build it, they're training, they're bringing
people over.
The big issue is going to be kind of the developing
south.
And in my mind it's going to be driven mostly
by capacity, and capacity building.
SIERRA: The developing south, which includes
Africa, much of the Middle East, Latin America,
and Southeast Asia, has been turning to China
for help building roads, bridges and other
infrastructure as part of the Belt and Road
initiative.
But it’s not just brick-and-mortar development.
In 2015, Beijing launched the Digital Silk
Road project, which focuses on providing digital
infrastructure to the same regions.
Under DSR, countries get help with things
like telecommunications, artificial intelligence,
e-commerce and surveillance.
In return, China gets to expand its global
tech footprint, promote tech-based authoritarianism,
and gain access to a far larger pool of user
data.
At least 16 developing countries have publicly
joined in, but the actual number could be
as high as 138.
SEGAL: So the Chinese in some ways have a
leg up because they're building the infrastructure,
right?
And while we saw, for example, Facebook talking
about building infrastructure in India and
other places, the way that they wanted to
do it alienated everybody.
So the U.S. has to figure out how do we compete
on infrastructure to have a chance that more
countries adopt that model.
SIERRA: So I've heard about a Tech Cold War
with China.
What impact is that having?
SEGAL: Yeah, so the Tech Cold War idea is
kind of a militarizing of this idea of different
models, and the threat of Chinese technology
itself.
So as Chinese tech companies globalized and
the social media platforms globalized, the
U.S. became increasingly worried about, oh,
did that create vulnerabilities in U.S. systems?
And who had access to the data?
The first and kind of archetypal example of
this was a company called Huawei, which is
a Chinese telecom provider.
And in particular Huawei was the leader on
5G, the fifth generation of telecom so far
for our cell phones, which is going to be
faster and have lower latency and allow self-driving
cars and all these other things.
Now, the U.S. doesn't produce 5G, we don't
have any telecom equipment manufacturers.
So there's Huawei and then there's two European
companies, Nokia and Ericsson.
And Huawei was expanding very quickly globally,
it's cheaper than Nokia and Ericsson, and
the United States basically started saying,
look, if you use Huawei, you're going to have
some real cybersecurity risks, because the
Chinese government can turn to Huawei and
say, turn it off or disrupt it or hand us
the data.
And so the U.S. kind of started campaigning
about ripping Huawei out of the US.
So some telecoms, particularly in the interior
of the U.S., was using Huawei, blocking Huawei,
you can't buy a Huawei handset, things like
that in the United States.
And then trying to convince other countries
not to use Huawei.
So Canada used Huawei, the U.K. used Huawei,
a lot of our European allies in the U.S.,
we really mounted this large campaign against
Huawei.
So that started to have some effect in the
Trump administration, countries for a number
of reasons, started saying, all right, we're
going to block Huawei from this next generation.
Now we see it with TikTok.
SIERRA: I was going to say it sounds similar
to the worries with TikTok?
SEGAL: So TikTok, the worries are more and
more people are using it and you put that
app on your phone and TikTok like all apps,
gets a lot of access to the data on your phone,
right?
Your location, your camera, possibly your
address book.
So there are concerns that it allows the Chinese
to do intelligence gathering, although I don't
think that's the primary concern, but there's
also a concern about what we would call ‘influence
operations.’
So with TikTok, we don't really know why we
see the videos we see.
The algorithm learns what you like and it
serves you up things.
So there's concern again, even though TikTok
says no, we've separated from ByteDance, the
Chinese company, that the Chinese can influence
stories that we see.
There were some cases, for example, in Hong
Kong when there were the protests about democracy,
they were very hard to find any of those stories
on TikTok.
So we now see a lot of concern about those
things and the U.S. is trying to convince
other countries to do the same thing.
Now again, the Chinese have always said, oh,
we know the U.S. intelligence services are
cooperating with the U.S. tech companies,
and so it's safer for us to start taking those
companies out of our systems.
So we see China trying to get rid of Cisco
and Qualcomm and the other ones.
And as we talked about at the beginning, they've
always blocked U.S. social media.
So we are beginning to see a kind of divergence
of those stacks, and we're beginning to see
Washington and Beijing reaching out to others
saying, ‘you guys should choose one of us,’
which the other countries don't want to do.
SIERRA: Right.
Well what about everyone else?
Especially big countries, you know, you mentioned
India or Brazil, where are they headed and
do they have to pick one of the, I guess,
three to join?
SEGAL: Yeah.
I think the big countries really don't want
to choose and will probably pick and choose.
So India for example, blocked TikTok and banned
TikTok and almost 200 other Chinese apps,
after the conflict in the border in the Himalayas,
and so to punish the Chinese, and they were
also concerned about information gathering
and data.
But we also see that the Indians have a lot
of concerns about communal violence and blasphemy
and other things.
And so they are looking to more tightly regulate
the internet than U.S. companies are comfortable
with.
And the Indians want to inspect both Chinese
product and U.S. product.
They have a strong and long tradition of technological,
or seeking technological autonomy, and don't
really want to do that.
So I think India, Brazil, Indonesia, South
Africa, they're gonna pick and choose.
SIERRA: Back when it launched, the internet
seemed limitless and borderless.
But that vision has given way to an era of
silos, one that is reinforcing regional information
bubbles, and driving us further and further
apart in our digital lives.
SIERRA: Do you see this splintering as having
been inevitable?
SEGAL: I do, because the internet really was
a kind of creation of a unique culture.
We talk about Silicon Valley, but this combination
of free speech, the First Amendment and a
very light regulatory hand, is really very,
very American.
That just doesn't exist anywhere else in the
world.
And so of course when other countries were
confronted with this platform, they brought
different political concerns to it.
So, it always struck me from the beginning
that of course, countries were going to try
to regulate.
And there were many people in the nineties
and the two-thousands that wrote about this.
They just weren't the dominant voices.
People were kind of like, ‘Oh, you political
scientists, what do you know?
What’re you talking about?
Or you're so narrow minded, you don't see
the liberatory potential of it.’
The debate in the United States has really
shifted and soured around 2016.
But before that, we really had a much more
optimistic view about the internet and the
technology companies themselves.
WHEELER: The downsides of a splintered internet
go to the same downsides of any situation
where there's partisanship.
We've all seen the pain and problems that
partisanship in the United States causes us.
A lot of it has to do with a lack of the capacity
to understand and accept reality.
If you've been taught that a different reality
exists, and if you shut your mind to the possibility
of an alternate point of view, how do you
come to a shared understanding of what geopolitical
concerns are, what rights are, what a person
is owed by their government and what we owe
to each other?
How do you even talk about reality?
The number of people who don't know that the
Tiananmen Square protests existed in China,
or who genuinely believe that it was all mocked
up.
The number of people who equate those two
things in China is large.
So how do you get to that shared sense of
reality?
The more we see that splintering, the consequence
of this, the more we're going to see a differentiation
in reality because information is how we make
our reality.
So that's where I think we're going with this.
Just in case you wanted to end on this super
depressing note.
SIERRA: That was awesome ... Thank you.
Yeah.
WHEELER: You're welcome.
No problem.
Absolutely no problem.
SIERRA: And we’re all doomed.
WHEELER: I'm here for your downers all day
long.
SIERRA: For resources used in this episode
and more information, visit CFR.org/whyitmatters
and take a look at the show notes.
If you ever have any questions or suggestions
or just want to chat, email us at whyitmatters@cfr.org.
You can subscribe to the show on Apple Podcasts,
Spotify, Stitcher, or wherever you get your
audio.
If you have the time and love the show you
could leave us a review - it helps us get
noticed, and we just love to read them.
Why It Matters is a production of the Council
on Foreign Relations.
The show is produced by Asher Ross and me,
Gabrielle Sierra.
Our sound designer is Markus Zakaria.
Our associate podcast producer is Molly McAnany.
Our intern this semester is Mormei Zanke.
Robert McMahon is our Managing Editor, and
Doug Halsey is our Chief Digital Officer.
This episode was the brainchild of our former
AP, Rafaela Siewart.
Extra help was provided by Kali Robinson and
Claire Klobucista.
Our theme music is composed by Ceiri Torjussen.
We’d also like to thank Richard Haass, Jeff
Reinke and our co-creator Jeremy Sherlick.
For Why It Matters, this is Gabrielle Sierra
signing off.
See you around!